I started at YC in 2013 as wifey's first
director of outreach and that meant
outreach to potential applicants so
people who were starting companies so
basically people like you and when I
started at YC
we had grown totally organically up
until that point so that meant that most
of the people applying to YC had heard
about YC through Paul Graham's essays
through reading Jessica Livingston's
book or because they were hacker news
readers so you know hacker news started
out as a reddit for tech and startup
news but if you've ever read the comment
it might not shock you to realize that
most of the hacker news community is is
male and if I had to guess even though
we don't have those specific
demographics I would guess white male so
basically I was tasked you know I
realized and I think you know Paul and
Jessica realized also that there are
smart hard-working people all over the
world and who should be starting
startups who weren't users of hacker
news so I was tasked with figuring out
where are these smart and hardworking
people and how do we get them to
consider applying do I see how do we get
them to consider starting a company if
they hadn't started already and and so
one of the things I end up working a lot
on at YC is finding ways to recruit
founders and from what is typically
underrepresented communities in tech and
then I also think a lot about what do we
do to support those communities once
they're here once they're starting
companies once you're in Silicon Valley
so to be honest I was not super aware of
the you know particular challenges that
a lot of women and people of color face
in tech when I started in 2013 so in
2012 I know the big mantra the big thing
everyone said is tech is a meritocracy
and I wanted to believe that you know I
wanted to believe and and so uh but you
know in my you know and I have been
personally very very lucky to work in an
environment that is very you know
supportive of me so working at YC for
example with Paul and just get first
then with Sam and the other partners I
was really lucky that they took a chance
on me that they give me a lot of
autonomy
and a lot of opportunity to do great
work
but even in a place where I think I have
had like a pretty great experience I've
had moments and I've had experiences
that make me wonder whether my life
whether my job would have been easier if
I were man right I've struggled with a
lot of you know anxiety about you know
am I meant to be here I might qualified
for this job and you know there are
certain experiences for example not so
long ago there were the founder for
example who had a meltdown he had a
meltdown about something that frankly I
or none of the partners had any control
over and frankly he didn't have any
control over it either but what does he
do he called me and he yells he starts
yelling uncontrollably and al I'm on the
phone with his founder I'm thinking why
am I the target for this I don't see him
yelling at other partners I don't see
him yelling at other male partners and
it just really bothered me and it really
set me back for a little while and so
frankly I you know in the work that I do
with founders that is what sort of
really makes me realize that we have
such a long way to go so for example
just in the last batch I had founders
tell me stories about being asked out on
dates by customers or by investors we
had one woman who was told by an
investor that she needed to find a white
male co-founder to pitch for her and we
had one woman at demo day she was a
non-profit founder who an investor came
up and said hey I'll give you $2,000 if
you babysit my kids I'm like why would
we I think what would strike me that we
are living in 2017 we are living in one
of the most liberal places most
progressive places in in the United
States if not the world so what I
believe is that we have an opportunity
here to do better and I'm excited for
you because I think that you know one of
the things that's most exciting is that
you have this opportunity to build a
culture from scratch you know companies
are basically like their own countries
and you have to give the opportunity to
build the world that you want to live in
and so some of the best founders I work
with are ambitious
they're idealistic they sign up to solve
these big problems and because you know
they see that they're unsatisfied with
something they see in the world and they
think like hey I can I have the
opportunity here to make real change so
you end up creating an ecosystem with
its own rules its own structure and its
own culture and that will be modeled
based on your personality and your
beliefs as founders so when Sam asked me
to host this workshop and I realized
that YC doesn't have a playbook
we don't have a playbook that we just go
to that walks early-stage companies
through how to think about DNI issues
but if you paid any attention to the
tech news in the past few years you've
realized that there's a momentum
building up around the conversations
around DNI and basically I think you all
realize at this point as I have that
most companies really feel and wish that
they had thought about this stuff
earlier earlier on in the life cycles of
their company and so what I decided to
do was I decided to talk to as many YC
companies as possible I wanted to find
out how you know how they thought about
DNI at their companies why it was
important to them I want to figure out
what was working what was exciting them
about this space and I think more most
importantly perhaps what is not working
and so I brought six of the people here
today that I thought I had the most
interesting and thoughtful conversations
with and they're going to share their
stories and observations with you so the
folks up here I believe will have you
know basically enough knowledge in the
space to fill a book but for today we
have pretty simple goals so first we
want to better define what diversity and
inclusion are so I think the words are
sort of so overused these days
especially in the media that they become
a little empty and so we'll talk briefly
about how we define each of these terms
in this context next we'll talk about
why did I was important for these
companies to think about and and when
they started thinking about it and a
little bit about why you should think
about it right now even at the very
earliest stages and then finally we want
to talk about how to build a culture
that embraces hard conversations through
diversity and inclusion even for me as a
woman and as a person of color can feel
like really
scary and awkward topics and and I you
know have a lot of anxiety about you
know offending or angering other people
that's what scares and kind of like
stresses me out the most but I also
realize that having these hard
conversations with your co-founders and
with you know the folks that work with
you these are some of the most important
conversations to have and so many of you
today and many of you watching are pre
hiring so we're not going to get into
the nitty-gritty of things like writing
job descriptions or how to conduct
interviews because I will but I will
share a page of resources for you that
you can reference when you're ready for
that stage but today I think we'll talk
about things that you can bake into your
culture from day one and you know that
will help you lay the foundation of
building a company where everyone is set
up to do their best work so hopefully
you'll leave here today with at least
one thing that you feel excited and like
prepared to try to implement or try out
so really quickly diversity and
inclusion and these are broad concepts
and they're going to mean different
things to different companies different
companies into different people so one
of my favorites definitions that I've
heard is by Verna Myers who is a lawyer
who does a lot of DNI consulting for the
legal world she describes diversity as
being invited to the party
whereas inclusion is being asked to
dance and so diversity in this context I
think will relate to finding and hiring
people from a range of backgrounds what
diversity is not is a code word for
gender or race and so diversity I think
can mean a lot of things it can mean you
know it can mean different code emic
backgrounds it can mean different ages
national origins religions work
experiences perspectives and it's going
to be up to you to decide what diversity
means for your company and what you'd
like to focus on first and what you
decide to focus on first is going to
change it's going to change depending on
certain factors it might depend on where
your company is based and what the
demographics are like in that region it
might depend on your product what is
going to be important and so if you want
to build a diverse team
you have to think about it deliberately
because one trap that happens is that
people focus on hiring individuals so
what happens you come up with a template
in your mind for what an ideal employee
would look like and then suddenly you
have an homogeneous team so many of the
alumni have talked to who are doing this
really well have said they've had to
stretch themselves they've had to think
about hiring as hiring a team so
basically like every you know a great
team won't all have the same strengths
and weaknesses the individuals won't
have the same strengths and weaknesses
they will have skills that complement
each other and if you think about it and
you're some of your context if you're
trying to choose a co-founder for
example and you wouldn't want to work
with a clone of yourself you would
ideally want to work with someone who
had complementary skills and so yet see
moving on to inclusion and let's see
sorry and most founders I talk to say
that after fundraising sort of the
ongoing hardest part of their job is
hiring it's hiring great talent but you
know one thing that a people related
challenge that is kind of less talked
about is retaining how do you get great
talent to stay at your company so you
can do the work to recruit talent but if
your culture is garbage they're probably
not going to stay for very long so the
cake board Center just released a tech
leaver survey which talks about why
people voluntarily leave their jobs
intact
and I recommend you read the whole thing
it's really interesting and it's not
incredibly long and these are just four
main takeaways so you know as the Kapoor
Center has laid out in their study this
is a huge problem and it's a very
expensive problem for tech and and it's
you know they've seen that DNI
initiatives if done right can improve
culture and really reduce turnover and
so you know Jen from lab review you'll
meet soon was talking about like what is
the flip side look like you know there's
a lot of these like terrible cases of
what happens when you don't think about
culture early but if you do build a
culture that is great and you know what
do you get you get a place where people
have strong personal bonds
they are loyalty remission you know they
stay a long time and soul ever I've been
specifically really impressed with their
at about a hundred employees and they
have a fifty fifty percent gender split
and I hope when Jen gets up here today
she talks a little bit more about the
positive benefits that she's seen at
lever as a result of them having thought
about culture and inclusion from a very
very early stage so in all my
conversations with YC alumni the thing I
heard repeated over and over again is
that inclusion is just one aspect of
building a great culture from scratch
inclusion is really about building a
culture where everyone can feel safe and
where people don't have to shy away from
having these like really tough and
awkward sometimes conversations so we'll
talk about some of those ways that
companies are tackling that challenge on
the panel but first let's talk really
briefly about why you might even want to
start thinking about this right now and
so there's a great McKinsey study that
came out in 2015 that I included in the
resources doc that I suggest you read
but here are some thoughts from YC
Alumni support of broswell is the
founder of a company called job well and
they connect black and Latin X and
Native American people with jobs and he
described why it's important in this way
and how can you build world-changing
products or services if you don't have a
complete understanding of the different
perspectives that exist in the world the
founders of ex-vivo another company YC
company learn this the hard way they
said we figured out early that if we
hired people who came from the same
academic background they approach
problems in the same way X people
brought up a really great example to
illustrate that point and I want to kind
of like do a quick experiment here so
how many of you keep your ketchup in the
fridge in the refrigerator how many of
you keep your ketchup in the cupboard
whoa
so there's a great episode of the
podcast reply-all where they interview
Scot Paige who's a professor at the
university of michigan who studies teams
so Scot says that language age you know
geography personal hardship that is all
going to influence how we solve problems
and he gave this example of where you
keep your ketchup so it turns out after
you know he did the study if you are
British or African American from the
South there there's a strong probability
that you will keep your ketchup in the
cupboard and if you are not either of
those things is a wrong probability that
you will keep your ketchup in the fridge
so you might think like why does this
matter
like this seems like a really trivial
point but what happens if you run out of
ketchup so if you are a ketchup in the
fridge person you open the fridge and
you might replace it with the things
that are next to the ketchup in the
fridge which are usually mustard or mayo
but if you are you know it catch up in
the cupboard person you might open the
cupboard and realize I'm out of ketchup
so you might put Multan agur on your
fries and so I love that example because
basically it showcases that like the
more diverse backgrounds you have
represented are the more associations
you get the more ways that you can you
have more pathways to solving problems
feel like honestly before hearing the
study I had no idea that humans even put
their ketchup in the cupboard I didn't
know people like that existed so I was
like wow this is blowing my mind and so
anyway recruiting might not be something
that you're thinking about right now and
but you know inclusion is in the words
of Mike and a who you'll meet very brief
in a couple minutes
inclusion is something you can tank
early on so there are really well-known
stories about what happens when you
don't start thinking about this at an
early stage so you know there is issues
with the the ride-sharing company will
not be named but let's also talk about
Airbnb so last year at the fortune
brainstorm tech conference the founder
of Airbnb Brian Chesky was talking about
how they were struggling with claims
that Airbnb enabled discrimination
especially against the African American
community and he admitted he was like I
think we were late to this issue he said
you know we realized that when we were
building a platform we were three white
guys Joe Nate Brian
and he said that there were a lot of
things we didn't think about so there
were a lot of steps that they're having
to reevaluate now and so now that we've
talked briefly about DNI how to define
it why you might want to think about it
I would love to invite the panel up and
to share their stories and observations
and have them introduce themselves as
well and let's bring you guys up okay
today you can pass them and this is
awkward if I'm standing is okay okay so
I would love you to go down the line and
introduce your side your name your
company your role and how big your
company is today sure my name is Joshua
I'm one of the cofounders of make school
we're building a college for computer
science the company's about 25 people
and I'm me and my co-founder are co-ceos
hi my name is Jen I was an early
employee at lever and we build hiring
software so if you've applied for a job
or an internship in the last year or two
you've probably used lever before as for
my role I found a various roles building
and leading teams and our product
customer success recruiting and employee
experience functions oh and we're over a
hundred and they're at 50-50 generous
bless the yellow have a nice but I it's
hard to do hi I'm Christina Cordova and
I manage the partnership scheme at
stripe stripe builds tools and
infrastructure to accept payments for
online businesses and we are about 750
people and I also spend a significant
amount of time on our diversity and
inclusion initiatives I think I'm like
here you guys hear me all right my name
is Kat Perez and I am the co-founder and
CTO at health Sherpa we are a technology
platform and team of people helping
individuals and role in marketplace
coverage we've enrolled over eight
hundred and forty thousand folks
our platform to date apart from products
and just leadership things I also lead
up DNI at health sharpen we're about 20
scaling up to about 40 50 in the on
season the open enrollment season my
name is mac and a a ta grow I'm the
founder and CEO of deaf color we help
black software engineers set and reach
ambitious career goals we are a team of
three my name is Mitchell Lee I'm one of
the two co-founders of penny which is a
personal finance app that you interact
with by way of conversation we are a
five person team awesome so one of the
things that was very clear to me as I
talked to a lot of YC alumni is that
diversity is sort of defined differently
for every company so I want to ask a
couple of you why was Dee and I
important for you and your company and
how did you define it let's start with
Jen so why was diversity and inclusion
important for us you know even though we
are on HR tech startup and really just
started as very organically like what do
we want to do as people and as
co-workers how can we build and includes
inclusive place to work and actually
once we started telling stories writing
blog posts about it we realized there's
a lot of resonating with both our
applicants and our customers they wanted
to know what are you doing differently
what can we learn from and realizing as
leaders in this space we had a lot to do
to show here's what we're experimenting
with and sometimes let's be real
sometimes make mistakes in and to be
honest what's been really cool is that
it makes a lot of difference and also
sales and growth so that we're able to
show you know this is how we're
approaching culture and inclusion with
this much intention it allows
prospective customers to look at well if
they are building culture their internal
company culture that way I want to know
what their software it looks like I want
to know what their product is like so
it's been a really huge benefit for us
that it gets to be an ongoing
conversation well I wanted to add let's
go with cat and I really liked hearing
about you know why you thought it was
important and like both for your
business case and for culture yeah yeah
so
for our team I mean I was I was higher
number seven and we and they we were
pretty small team we scaled up really
quickly but by nature of who were
serving we are serving folks of lower
income folks who would qualify for
subsidies in the marketplace Kaiser
Family Foundation released a report I
think for 2015 the majority of the
uninsured under 65 market in the United
States are people of color over half so
55 to 60 percent specifically latina
Hispanic communities as well as black
and African American communities so for
us it was it's a no-brainer I mean our
mission is to enroll these people give
them access to coverage let them know
what options they have you can't do that
if you have a team that does not reflect
that audience so it's for us it was
really simple and straightforward why we
needed to do that and I'd love to hear a
little bit about stripe like why it's
important and you know how you defined
it how you interact with the founders as
well yeah so I would say on our side we
thought about this really early but
probably not in the way that you would
think a company would both of our
founders are Irish and immigrated to the
United States a lot of our really early
employees are also immigrants everywhere
from Honduras to Kenya to Sweden all in
our first like 20 or so employees and I
think one of the reasons for that is
because of our core mission which is
really looking at you know how can we
enable economic opportunities and access
to creating an online business no matter
where you are in the world we've
launched products like Atlas which
enable entrepreneurs around the world to
get set up with like a u.s. entity and a
US bank account which you know if you
are an entrepreneur in Cuba or if you
are an entrepreneur in Canada very
difficult to do regardless and I think
for us early on it was about you know
how can we build this into our culture
because we know that we need to launch a
product that works in 20 plus countries
now hopefully every country eventually
and we need to have people on board to
really understand what are the right
products to be building for different
entrepreneurs all around the world and
how can we make it easier for people to
become on
the other piece really early on was in
working on diversity and inclusion
making sure that we had a direct line to
ultimately people who were making
decisions that affect inclusion and
diversity across the company so for us
that means me working very very closely
with our CEO and CFO and meeting with
them every other week on like how are we
doing on these various different aspects
of diversity and inclusion throughout
the company and making sure that they
are aware of what's going on and that
they are approving every single thing
every step of the way and that way I can
go about what I need to do to make
things happen within the company so
giving you that autonomy and that
ability to actually make change right
where you see needed so one next
question I had is like when did you
first start thinking about DNI and a
couple of you had some interesting
conversations than I thought so I want
to talk to you about make school and
your experience sort of being two guys
starting this company when did the
conversation first come up so the
conversation first came up for us when
we started talking to some of our
students the first start program we had
we had a particular female student
Sophie who from my and my co-founders
perspective was this confident badass
girl who was building this amazing app
and and we never really realized that
she had a lot a bit of a struggle when
she was actually going through our
certain program and it wasn't until a
year later where we started to talk to
some of our students about what their
experience with our program was like and
where we really heard that behind the
scenes there were a lot of concerns
around how she fit into the environment
of the summer program and it's important
to acknowledge that it's not the
environment was explicitly sexist or
still solely discriminatory but there's
a lot just in terms of the culture and
the language that you might not
obviously flag as this is something that
might make someone feel uncomfortable or
feel feel not included and it was only
really hearing her experiences that that
made us think one level deeper not just
the world surface level a surface level
a challenge but one level deep in that
how do we go above and beyond to try to
make make the summer environment a lot
more inclusive for for people like
Sophia so it was really shocking to us
to hear about this experience and
because we didn't we thought that things
were actually pretty good and that we
had a had a pretty good culture in the
program but it wasn't until we actually
had these kind of hard
stations and and got some very candid
feedback to realize that we had a long
way to go to to improve that environment
can you give one example of something
that she experienced that you didn't
realize was making was like giving her a
hard time or making her like less able
to perform well yeah I mean some of the
things were we're a little bit less
gendered and it was around she was
someone who was very athletic and had a
lot of hobbies around or not not just
computer science and app development
most of students were very focused
around app development computers and
video games and as a result didn't
necessarily feel like she fit in
socially as well with a lot of the other
students and a lot of is also just just
feeling whether like she had a place in
the environment when you when you step
into a room where you're one of the few
girls or one of the few people of color
and it becomes a lot tougher to feel
like you fit in and your doubt whenever
you're having questions or struggle is
about I don't know how to build this
feature I don't know how to solve this
bug and there's a two questions that are
being asked is one is it just that I
didn't learn this or also is it because
I don't fit here because I'm I'm not a
person who should be a programmer and
that kind of rhetoric to society has
kind of pushed especially at the high
school level where you tend to have a
lot more boys who are in computer
science or math classes and that that
sort of second second line of
questioning makes people are in her case
and other students we've heard make them
less willing to actually go and approach
instructors to ask for help because they
feel like I should know this and I
shouldn't be going to get help for this
kind of topic and so being more
proactive that offering help definitely
and one one example that you gave that I
thought was really like stuck with me
was that you know when she didn't know
something you know some of the very
young men in the class high schoolers
would be like oh you don't know that and
and I think just like trying to like I
guess like coach people through like
here's an appropriate reaction when
someone asks a question and I think
would like sharing a really like small
personal side note on that is that like
for the first year for example at YC I
didn't I used to wear dresses all the
time and I didn't I wore like jeans and
I'm like a graphic tee because I was
like I just want to fit in like I'm like
I realized I was doing reason with way
more brain cycles and to like really try
to like fit in and like be taken
seriously then then I like needed to be
but I think if I wish I'd had this
station because yes I think that other
people have you know felt the same thing
and I'd never talked about it until
actually right now so there you go
sharing a story first time okay and I
would love to talk to you much about
penny because you are one of the kind of
you and I think Deb caller are probably
the most recent companies to go through
YC and and this is something that you've
thought about a lot and so why are you
thinking about it your team of five so I
guess I should address the elephant in
the room which is I am a white male on a
DNI panel
we raised a round of funding for penny
and started to look to expand our team
at the time we were just two people and
would a little bit of backstory here
penny is a conversational app that helps
you with your finances it's really
intended to help people who struggle
with financial literacy or just find
finances intimidating that correlates
strongly with people that don't make a
lot of money lower-income people so we
were building this interface which has
this personality and I'm a prolific
emoji user and so penny ended up using a
lot of emojis and one day my fiancee
kind of tapped me on the shoulder and
she says I think Penny's flirting with
me
I was like whoa that no I just use emoji
that's that's my style but kind of
experiences like that and I heard from
other friends as well really hammered
home the point that if we want to build
a product that's accessible to everyone
we need to have a team that looks like
the people that we're trying to help and
is kind of representative of the group
of people that were trying to build for
so that was a that was one of the
turning moments for why we need to focus
on this right now and okay and Mac and a
you I mentioned I mentioned it briefly
that you think that you know inclusion
is something that you can tank really
early on so are there any examples
you've seen either on the positive or
negative side of companies that you've
worked with that are doing this really
well
yeah there's a lot I could say on this
one and I'll start with an example just
from my own organization so clearly
we're diversity organization so it
matters a lot to us both for the team
that we build but also the membership
that we build and one of my like big
mistakes early on was taking it for
granted so I'm a black man so I was like
okay this should be easy but I actually
very quickly when starting the
organization fell into this trap of okay
the initial members will be the people
that I know because that's who's easiest
to start with turns out they're not a
lot of black women and software
engineering in that in that initial set
of people that I brought together and
like right away it became like a very
clear issue that the gender balance in
our group was was off and it's something
that we've worked on since then it's
still not where we sell a lot and it's
something we keep an eye on but even
just like realizing that even I had a
blind spot was a big wake-up call for me
so I'm guessing everyone has a blind
spot for four different groups so I
think they're they're small signals the
other thing I'll say is just
piggybacking on people feeling like they
belong somewhere that's another thing I
think it's really easy to mess up just
realizing that you and your company are
constantly sending out signals of who
belongs and who doesn't so for us
something as simple as sending out our
members to go in off sites all right
like I was making a list of like here's
some all sites you can consider and I
just put a list of things that I enjoy
which are like ziplining or rock
climbing and for some people that was
great for other people it sends a subtle
signal again like hey is this group for
me do I belong here so I had to actually
go back to the drawing board and
thankfully we had a lot of different
people on our team who could add
different perspectives and also within
the membership who could help fill out
that list to be something everyone would
find something that appealed to them and
so one of the things that I think I
heard from all of you and all the alumni
I talked about is that like one of the
major kind of obstacles to start
implementing like really you know
impactful D&I programs is
is like getting people to have tough
conversations it's getting people even
if they're uncomfortable to have to
share and have these conversations so
Jen can you talk a little bit about you
what's going to come next is sort of
inspired but by what Jen told me about a
panel she heard about a Pinterest but
then also and talk about how you've
implemented that at lever yeah the
particular problem we were trying to
solve for at that time about a year and
a half ago was this question of how do
you make inclusion truly inclusive to
make inclusion and culture building a
company-wide activity it's not just oh
that's like the women's issue or that's
like the racial minorities issue so
something we realized was that when we
had events and different discussions
about inclusion you know there was a
smaller subset of the company that was
very active very passionate about it and
actually have a larger subset that
considered themselves kind of like a
little bit on the sidelines so don't get
me wrong they thought it was a good idea
they were very supportive but for
whatever reason they were a little bit
hesitant to like jump really deep in and
be visible leaders for it so it's kind
of wrapping this around my head and I
met a head of inclusion at Pinterest
Candice an event and she told me about
this event that they had called sorry I
didn't mean to offend and what they did
was put members of the majority group I
think a lot of Engineers you know white
males put them on a panel just like this
and create a safe space where they were
able to talk about mistakes missteps
here's something I just had no idea
about I said something offended someone
and I was so mortified but you know by
having leaders and by having you know
their colleagues speak openly about
these events really set a tone for the
culture right saying like you are not
going to be vilified by saying the wrong
thing we are going to assume best
intentions and really try to go from
there as a team so what we ended up
creating inspired by that idea was a
session called DNI for supporters some
internal seminar led by actually
somebody on our team who is also from a
majority group a straight white male
engineer and the fact that maybe was ill
led by him I had took two different
factors so one you know
because when the person leading it is
someone from the majority group people
are like oh I'm like way more curious
about it like maybe I should go even
though previous events that they didn't
really seem like they were for me and
then second again really designing is
for with that audience in mind the
subtitle to that seminar was DNI for
dummies so it's like if you're ever
confused or uncertain and you just
didn't want to say the wrong thing so
you've been holding yourself back this
is the space to come for you and it
ended up being really successful and a
lot of people who previously weren't
actively involved came and shared really
personal stories and opened up and just
to wrap this up I think something one of
my co-workers have said so this is a
black male co-worker of mine who said
you know when the cause is in your own
it can feel really uncomfortable to
speak out on behalf even if you really
really want to because again that's fear
of saying the wrong thing being
misinterpreted being attacked even there
really is a deliberate effort you have
to make for you know your future
employees your culture to say that this
is okay we're going to navigate through
these things just like you would with
any business problem for a growing
company so in the spirit of getting
people to talk about hard things and
having hard conversations I would like
everyone on this panel to share a story
about you know a mistake they made or
misstep and something that they wish
they could have a do-over on and when
they started thinking about you know D&I
at their workplace or so and let's talk
about our mistakes do you want to start
you can but mom's here I think I went
already
oh yeah I messed up on gender balance
for for the organization at the at the
start and I'm still still developing
more strategies to to sustainably fix
that issue so I've made a lot of
mistakes I I will say that we're pretty
early on and so for us I don't view it
so much as mistakes it's just kind of
learning opportunity there were a lot
learning opportunities as we started
this process how do you approach the
subject with people that you're
interested in recruiting how do you
position it within your own company and
have an open dialogue there there were
also just small missteps like we had one
woman that actually ended up joining our
team we had a dinner with the team and
the way that we were like positioned at
the dinner was just very aggressive it
was like a noisy environment she was
surrounded by men and we were peppering
her with questions and like that's just
not a way to make somebody feel
comfortable and open up with you is kind
of like on a personal level so there are
a lot but I do think that we're learning
and we're getting better at this and
step one is just talk about it openly
yeah so we we had a few missteps I'd
like to call them and early on when we
started our DNI initiatives we started
about two years ago and at the time you
know I come on as higher number seven so
we were still pretty small made the
really big mistake of assuming everyone
had the same perception of what
diversity and inclusion meant to each
and every one of us and our lived
experiences and that means everyone
including you know whites as males on
the team right so Jenni talked about
this but one of our biggest misstep
switch to stop not necessarily even
practicing this concept of inclusion
with with our whites of small team
members right they their thoughts matter
and they need to be involved in the
conversation as well so I think that was
our that was our biggest mistake is just
assuming a team of seven everyone
conceptually agrees we should do this
but not really having that tough
uncomfortable conversation about it and
then the second thing I'll just add
there is we approach it as a to-do list
which is a terrible thing to do we were
overly ambitious we had like seven
initiatives we wanted to roll out at the
same time definitely don't do that it's
simple one
is enough we learn to approach MVP style
start small because this stuff is really
emotionally taxing and intense and
triggering triggering for people so so
yeah just starting small would have been
something we would have changed from the
start so I would tell you for us at
stripe the probably one of the biggest
mistakes we made fairly early on was we
need to hire a pretty significant number
of engineers in a very fast period of
time in our early growth and we hadn't
necessarily hired the number of
engineers that we were looking to hire
in that period of time which was about
three months at that rate ever in our
history and we set a really like
audacious the goal in terms of like the
percentage of women and percentage under
represented minorities that would make
up this kind of batch of engineers that
we wanted to bring on in that short
period of time and so we set this like
lofty goal we had all these aspirations
but we actually had no plan for how to
meet that goal so of course we
completely failed and it was a very hard
time I think in the company because we
you know effectively we hired all the
engineers that we wanted hire but not
many of them were people of color or
women and as a result we had to sit down
as a company and say like yeah we
screwed up and we had to admit that like
add in all hands in front of our entire
company and start thinking about okay
well what are we going to do to fix this
right because we are going to continue
to hire engineers and we need to set up
a plan so that we can do that in a more
effective way so what we did from that
point on was say that you know I think
at stripe at the time we had this kind
of disconnect between recruiting and
hiring managers so I think in a lot of
ways
hiring managers people who need to add
engineers onto their team think about in
the context of life well recruiting is
bringing me these candidates and so I'm
going to you know find the best ones and
bring them through my hiring pipeline
but the reality is that as a hiring
manager it's your responsibility for
what you're
looks like at the end of the day and you
need to take an active role in that
hiring process so we actually
implemented two quarters ago a goal
effectively saying that every
engineering manager is required to bring
an underrepresented candidate so a
person of color or a woman for
engineering all the way through to the
on-site stage of our hiring pipeline at
stripe and this really put the onus on
the end managers to do this because we
won created a public internally public
spreadsheet in the company of all the
end managers and which one of them had
met the goal and so they could see this
their team members could see this and so
if they weren't dedicating the time
necessary to meet this goal everyone
would know about it and so that really
put the power in the hands of the hiring
managers to say well okay like how can I
go out there and meet people who are not
in my direct network and how can I
ensure that we are bringing more people
from different backgrounds into the
funnel of our hiring pipeline and we've
3x the number of women in engineering
that we would normally hire during that
period of time through the effort cool I
have a story about how we made a mistake
and a really valuable lesson was how we
were going to treat and kind of deal
with other future problems like that so
we have a employee resource group called
lever rest and that's what we call
female employees of lever it's a fact
channel and a dinner I think like 2 or 3
times a year to talk about issues you
know resources mentorship I had found
out that about a year and a half ago
somebody had created a private slack
channel called lever dudes and so this
is a little bit of gray area and I think
you will find the pattern in that you
know the grey areas and the kind of like
a awkward and uncomfortable and vigorous
problems all the hardest because if you
look at the channel there was nothing
like super wrong with it but there was
this tone that could be interpreted as a
little bit of mocking right so it was
said you know something like well they
have a leverets channel so it's only
fair and there are some jokes that again
nothing super crazy but it didn't make
people who were in it actually other men
did
feel good about it so when I was brought
up to me we talked about how one of our
standards and principles for DNI is this
phrase the standard that you Sariah if
you see something say something the
standard that you walk past is a
standard you accept and even though it's
comfortable it was our job as startup
employees as leaders to do something
about it so we reached reach out to one
of our founders Randall who was
incredibly empathetic listen to the
situation took it really seriously the
problem here was that again
undermining the other leverets channel
in the group and also if left alone it
could potentially lead to a little bit
of like us versus them mentality if we
were to grow right so he ended up
addressing the employee in question you
know Subaru professionally like not
trying to call him out just saying that
like hey this is not okay so I'd like to
talk about what happened again really
trying to understand and listen but then
also draw the lines and then this is a I
think the next part what he did was
really stepping up as a leader and again
you know like stripe we decided to
address it at our next All Hands and I
think that's been one of our key
learnings like you have to address
things it's not fun nobody goes up to
all hands in front of your entire
company saying like this happened it was
super uncomfortable and awkward so you
have to do it otherwise it becomes an
elephant in the room so Randall you know
address the entire company I was really
interesting was that he started the
story saying by being very honest about
a mistake that he had made in the past
so when the Liveris group was first
formed and it was just the four of us
women just going out to dinner he made a
joke about like well maybe I'll grab
some of the engineers and go and get
pizza or something like the same night
and it wasn't until later he realized
that wasn't actually a very you know
that wasn't what he meant to say because
again if you think about why that group
exists in the first place because women
maybe may not be minorities but they are
minorities in tech and therefore they
had experiences you know burdens
hardships that you might not even know
about so the reason the group exists is
not to have fun and go out and go to
drinks and talk about I don't know nail
polish it really is about you know the
work and what can we do to support
ourselves each other
and just for future employees and future
inclusion and just being really honest
and authentic as a leader I think made a
huge difference
later that day in flag multiple
employees both and also in person went
up to Randall to thank him to say things
like you know my previous startup
founders would never do anything like
that I feel really grateful and lucky to
work for a place where the leaders
really care about the people and it's
very human and authentic so I think that
was a lesson that we learned it's not
just to address it one on one you want
to prevent it from happening in the
future you know very easily could a new
hire could have been joined you know six
months later the same thing happens over
again so how do you address it head on
really step up as a leader it's not
going to be fun sometimes it's not going
to be comfortable but that is your
responsibility but the thing is people
will remember the stone you said what
you say your employees remember and it
gets embedded into the culture as you
grow yes to Greek ones one cat touched
on earlier which is this concept of
feigning surprise and so in their first
summer we had a certain students to take
a zip up your folder and email it to us
and students would say hey and I don't
know how to zip up a folder and we'd say
wait you're not a zip of a folder that's
like such a basic thing and but it
operates under this assumption that this
person has gone through the same
education and upbringing that you have
such that they'll actually know disdain
the Chaston than they do and so that was
a big one and especially from a
standpoint of a teacher not a really
great thing for a student to hear the
second one was starting from very early
in the company we had a very like strong
voice culture in meetings we had so
anytime there's some sort of discussion
about different topics it get preheated
voices would raise not in an egg that I
guess argumentative or in a healthy
debate way but it also means that people
who are more introverted or more
soft-spoken suddenly don't have as much
voice and it's really a big problem when
you're including those folks in meetings
and they're not really getting a chance
to speak and so and those it into big
big mistakes that we made and the the
main thing that we've done from a
cultural standpoint to make it help
people work on these mistakes is really
assuming assuming negligence and not
malice I mean these kind of sorts of
situations and really focusing on where
people are going as opposed to
necessarily where they are and both my
children and I were quite young when we
were starting the company so had
lots of lots of mistakes in terms of
leadership and management and it's only
because we have a culture where other
folks on team are willing to understand
that we're constantly trying to improve
similarly if you're if you notice some
behavior and you says say something
about it it's important not to make the
person feel that they are a bad person
for having said this but really just
help coach them so that a year from now
they'll be a lot better in these kind of
situations cool so now and you've also
sort of talked a little bit about some
things you're doing that are going well
but like you know shifting a little bit
from the mistakes that you've made in
the past or that your organization's
have made in the past let's start
talking about things that you're trying
but you're excited about that that are
you know paying off that are that you
think are going well in terms of you
know building this you know great
culture from scratch is it going well
for anyone yeah and I think it's like
the thing is it's like we know there's
no easy button but if there are any like
lights that we can follow yeah I can
only share what's worked for us what's
worked for us may not work for everyone
there is no playbook the one size or
blueprint that you know one size fits
all for us at healthcare but what we did
when we were hiring is we leveraged pop
tools not to be mistaken with the other
pot so people ops tools that's what
that's what it stands for one
specifically that we use it's called it
was called unitive it's a cape or
capital a portfolio company they're
called talents owner now and we use it
to run our job description through it
and the job description check would
would score the job description it would
call out words that were heavily biased
and the reason we did that was to
obviously cast the white or not so super
easy tool to use
they had other features like the blind
resume review as well as scoring
questions and making sure that each
person who was interviewing a candidate
was asking every single person the same
question and those questions map back
the competencies and skills that you
need right so it's not this when you're
start up at you going to do things
within a scrappy way but we finally
built some structure around our
interview process and what we have what
we ended up finding after rolling out
one initiative is we ended up hitting
our diversity goals we 2x our hispanic
latina hires and team members as well as
our black team members as well so so it
totally worked
another thing I like to throw in there
as we had that new team using leveraging
that initiative is we hadn't plus 85
percent revenue growth as well so I
would like to you know be that to the
team that we had in place so it's just a
testament to the fact that hiring
diverse team members especially when
you're serving diverse communities
really does impact your bottom line yeah
I actually get this question a lot
because of what our organization is a
lot of founders of small companies will
come up and ask hey how do I hire more
Latin X or black or female engineers and
what I usually actually tell them is
look if your company is four five ten
people what you should really think
about is what are the attributes and
skills that you need on the team and be
really honest about those things so if
you're for example if you're building an
Ag tech company right and all of your
employees are from cities that may not
be the most effective thing when you're
trying to sell endo it has ever been on
a farm so I think it's like step one for
me is really taking a really honest look
at what you need your employees to be
able to do and what specific things
matter to you at the stage that you're
at and then hiring against those things
as opposed to just trying to like check
the boxes or make your numbers look a
certain way because you know when you're
larger you know the press will be
looking at your at your stats figure out
what's important to you at your stage
and then hire against that so I think
the thing that we probably have done
best is start early we started thinking
about this when we were two and three
people that's important both because the
people that you hire early on are
eventually going to go on to be the
leaders at your company and hire their
own teams and so you want to make sure
that you're building the team now that
you eventually want to have it's also
important because if you end up as a
team of
fifteen white and Asian dudes sitting in
a room and can start trying to
incorporate diversity into your team at
that point good luck because I mean
people don't want to be a like a token
diversity candidate or feel alienated by
a culture that's already in place so
that's a big one
we've also been pretty proactive so you
mentioned kind of blinding the resume or
putting together
good job descriptions that at a very
early stage is not quite enough because
you're working with a much smaller
funnel so we've been very proactive
about saying no we're actually seeking
out people of different backgrounds and
different cultures to to try to
incorporate them into the team early on
and and so like partnering with like
different organizations that can kind of
help broaden your you're recruiting
funnel there was something that we I
think did well early on so for us
talking about these issues and whether
it's community culture diversity and
talking about that ad effectively reset
points so for our education programs
when the programs actually start is a
really good time but with the company if
you can't always go back and reset to
the very beginning so at a company
off-site let's say in January right
after everyone's come back from when
your break usually is a good time to
address these kind of topics because
whatever impression you set and whatever
culture you start building in the first
few weeks of the new year will typically
last throughout the year and the second
piece is providing a mentorship
especially for our students providing
mentorship pool of people who look like
them and feel like them we have one of
our alums Lesley actually works at lever
she's been amazing in terms of creating
a support group for our current female
students in our college program and
that's gone gone a really long way to to
helping that and finally just talking
about the numbers it's not you shouldn't
be ashamed if your numbers are not very
diverse last year and in the first year
of our college program we had one girl
out of about 22 students which was not
great and but we still talked about that
and we thought about how can we actively
improve that and because
it was open an open dialogue we could
think about how to make plans to address
that and now we've had we have about
seven girls out of 40 of our 36 students
and one hundred percent retention
throughout the year which is a big
improvement for last year and so for
both programs as well as for the staff
we've started talking about the numbers
when they weren't great and then
continued to continue to increase and
improve them here every year if you take
one minute and then I think all ala yeah
this is soccer yeah keep it short that
so you're hearing a lot of answers both
on the diversity side holding inclusion
side and I can talk a lot about there
but one thing that I think adding on to
those shoots at the end said really you
know figure out what works for your
company that might not be for every
other company for us we are a SAS or
ghen efficient in that we have a quite a
large sales part of the company and one
of the very common associations like
what makes a really good sales person is
they're like oh we should get some
athletes in here right like athletes not
the best salespeople and I have no doubt
that some of the best salespeople are in
fact previous athletes but that doesn't
mean that you know if you weren't an
athlete you're going to be not a good
enough right so it really took to
examining some of these biases and
beliefs that we have in the valley and
workplaces in general and really looking
at is that actually true and is that
going to work for us at lever so we've
been able to have
yeah just make you know the previous
athletic you know previous college
athletic experience required like taking
that out of job descriptions and making
sure people are not being punished or
feeling like they're being left out
because they didn't have this certain
background last thing I'll say is we did
probably 20 things to improve our intern
diversity for this past year so in 2016
we had 11% women and underrepresented
minorities in our intern class which was
you know failure mistake and this year
we had over 41 percent women in
underrepresented minorities in our
intern class and we over doubled the
intern program
and I would say one of the things that
we did in particular that had that
effect was we created multiple ways to
actually get into our intern pipeline so
your traditional way of showing up at a
career fair for example or applying to
our website we're still ways that we
looked at candidates but we found that
all the other technology companies were
looking at those exact same candidates
and you are looking at the same
candidates that had two other great
internships at Google and Facebook etc
and you were all fighting over those
particular candidates when the reality
is you're looking for capabilities at
the internship stage you're not
necessarily looking for people who have
tons of experience because the
likelihood is if you're in college you
probably don't have very much experience
at all so how can we hunt for people who
are like have those fantastic
capabilities that we need that we think
are going to do really well at stripe
and so one of the things that we did was
create two additional application paths
one was a coding challenge that you
could do in your own free time and then
submit that challenge to us and you'd
actually go straight to a phone
interview you didn't even have to talk
to a recruiter and the other path was a
show us your code option so we went to a
bunch of events like Black Society of
engineers at certain different colleges
the Grace Hopper etc and we said if you
just take out your computer and show
with a project if something that you've
built if we think the code is good like
you automatically get to next stage
right so how can we think about
candidates as more than just their
resume especially when in reality at a
college stage their resume probably
doesn't really matter that much yeah all
right so we are at time so to kind of
thank you all for for sharing all your
stories and I realize a lot of you are
pretty hiring and so you aren't thinking
about some of these issues but I'm going
to I created a resource list and it's
sort of a living document so I will list
everything that you guys mentioned all
the resources and tools that you've used
and where you know steven is going to be
sharing that with the class and with
everyone online and Jen I'd wanted you
to talk a little bit about the framework
for creating like ongoing DNI programs
but I'm just going to have you we don't
have time I will hopefully work with you
on a blog that you can blog both and
levar also has an incredible series it's
a 10 part series that walks through kind
of D&I for four companies and that I
also added on the
sources list of great places to start if
you're looking to read up more on this
and so we will be sharing that list with
you and also kind of putting together
all your notes and then anything else
that we missed this is such a meaty
topic and there's you know a lot here
but thank you also for for listening and
you are feel you feel free to reach out
to me with any questions that you have
either for the speakers or for me I'm
cat ka T at Y Combinator comm and I can
connect you to any of these any of these
ladies and gentlemen if that's desired
so thank you again and thank you alright
private pod
[Applause]